mais pour maxime thiébaut docteur en
droit public il faut bloquer et ce
projet de loi portant sur l'extension du
passani terre et qu'ils jugent
liberticide écouter leur était prévu
dans tous les cas que le conseil
constitionnel de soient saisis donc à
cette occasion est le cercle droits et
libertés et divers professeurs de droit
et avocat
on va faire ce qu'on appelle des
procédures de portes étroites c'est à
dire qu'on va écrire au conseil
constitutionnel pour expliquer en cours
à 7 cette loi est attentatoire aux
libertés fondamentales
c'est une manoeuvre ti qui ne respectent
pas nos libertés fondamentales et qui au
demeurant en poussant les gens à faire
des soins n'entraînera pas ne permettra
pas d'entraîner la responsabilité de
l'état parce que c'est là aussi le côté
pervers du pass sanitaire c'est que
l'état n'oblige pas les gens de droit à
aller se faire vacciner
mais de fait les contraint à le faire
pour avoir une vie normale
et comme ça mais elles n'entraînent pas
sa responsabilité dont tu auras la
saisine du conseil constitutionnel du
moins pas par nous mais par 60 sénateurs
et nous participons par cette procédure
de portes étroites et puis une fois que
la loi sera votée une fois qu'elle sera
promulguée pardon et que les décrets
d'application seront prix bas on saisira
le conseil d'état par divers moyens des
référés suspension d'aller faire liberté
des recours en excès de pouvoir
pour pouvoir faire tomber toutes les
mesures liberticides que le conseil
constitutionnel n'aurait pas n'aurait
pas censuré